hallo herzlich willkommen in meine taten
welt heute gibt es bei mir super leckere
kekse und die kekse sind nicht nur super
lecker sondern sitzen doch ganz einfach
ihr braucht für den teig nämlich nur
drei zutaten und ich zeige ich euch
jetzt gleich für den teig braucht ihr
nur 50 gramm butter 100 g mehl und 80 km
hotel und die gibt jetzt alle in eine
schüssel und knetet daraus einen
mürbeteig
den teig wollte jetzt am besten zwischen
einer folie aus da brauchte nämlich gar
kein mädel dazu
da hat es bei mir etwa zwei millimeter
und ich stecke jetzt einfach kleine und
große herzchen aus
und die lege ich jetzt auf ein
vorbereitetes backblech
den rest knetet er wieder zusammen
wollte ihn wieder aus dann sticht die
rechtlichen platz hinaus aus dem teig
habe ich jetzt insgesamt sieben große
und neun kleine plätzchen ausgestochen
und den rest habe ich einfach so drauf
gedrückt dann kann man ja mit packen und
dann kann man den sondern einfach
vernaschen die klingt jetzt bei 200 grad
etwa vier bis sechs minuten gebacken
nach dem backen sehen sieht so aus die
last die jetzt kurz hier abkühlen und
dann gibt es sie auf ein gitterrost
damit sie komplett auskühlen können als
zuckerguss mache ich jetzt heute als
spritz glas so beziehungsweise realizing
ihr könnt aber auch den ganz normalen
zitronen zuckerguss benutzen denn das
rezept dazu findet ihr in dem kürbis
keks video jetzt nehmt ihr euch dieses
und ich mache heute nur eine kleine
menge und davon braucht ihr etwas eiweiß
das kommt hier
ich nehme jetzt nicht das komplette
eiweiß und nur einen kleinen teil und
das restliche könnt ihr doch noch anders
verwendet stelle kurz weg zu dem eiweiß
kommt jetzt noch im spritzer
zitronensaft
ihr könnt auch eine prise salz benutzen
die prise salz oder zitronensaft bewirkt
einfach dass die eiweißstrukturen
schneller zerstört werden das rührt
jetzt einmal kurz durch
und dann gebt ihr so viel puderzucker
dazu bis ihr die gewünschte konsistenz
haut wenn ihr ein komplettes eiweiß
bereits ins etwa 220 gramm futter zu
können
wer jetzt noch will kann sich in
zuckerguss einfärben das mache ich jetzt
wieder mit diesen worten isync ahlers da
nehme ich mir ein kleines bisschen raus
nicht zu viel und früher das unter die
als stütze lassen beim rot nämlich etwas
mehr ich möchte ein dunkles rot
kräftiges fahren kommen jetzt wieder in
vorbereitete spritzbeutel ihr könnt die
aber auch auf inseln
wenn ihr das lieber macht für mich geht
noch einfacher
und finden einfach wieder zu drehen
so schneidet euch dann hier eine ganz
kleine spitze ab und dann könnt ihr die
knicks schon damit dekorieren
die großen flächen könnt ihr dann mit
einem pinsel verstreichen oder mit einem
zahnstocher so wie hier
wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr dann noch so
kleine zuckerperlen drauf geben
wenn ihr so punkte habt und dann muss
noch flüssig ist dann zieht er mit dem
zahnstocher von oben nach unten
und so entstehen kleine herzchen
euro
also mir persönlich schmecken kekse
immer besser wenn ich sie mit zitronen
und pudern zuckerguss verziert
aber dieses eiweiß spritzt glas so
bleibt einfach schön hart und die könnt
ihr auf über längere zeit lagern
jetzt wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachbacken ich hoffe ich konnte euch
etwas anregungen geben und dann bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss